so there you go
i mean you could be that too the instant
takes an interest in politics and saving
the world you might destroy all that
it's going bye-bye i promise i just
disagree with you i mean
because you have to you have to do it
like you've said this many times before
i'll bet you yeah i'll bet you uh a
bottle of stoli
that you can get uh if you get joe rogan
to get highly politically active and
call out the system for all the [ __ ]
that it is in a very pointed and
determined fashion
uh and he doesn't get destroyed i'll
give you i'll give you the vodka the
vodka yeah
that sounds like a pretty damn great
deal so but this you've said this
i mean there's no living heroes my
friend
no living hero i just no living heroes
it's it's just difficult you just have
to be good at it
i mean if you just say generic political
things no
no you it you're going to be taken down
but the more heroic
you are the more beautiful you are
the more you will be made to suffer if
they cannot get you on reputation if
jesus himself came down
i don't know if i ever read uh i
probably have never read to you the hit
piece i did on jesus
you don't know about this no i did not
know i did hit pieces on all of the best
people in the world
wow so whoever it was who cured cancer
you know discovered new particles or
whatever it is
i did a hit piece against them to prove
that i can do it to anybody
around anything at any time except eddie
van halen as we were talking about well
eddie van halen is now dead
but if if this was a uh a situation
you know hot for teacher cancelled
disrespectful absolutely
also you know packaging uh
female objectification for young men
clearly eddie van gaal is one of the
worst people alive
but was the skill
the incredible inspiration that is just
radiating from his music inspires so
many millions that they will fight those
canceled pieces they they will fight
though this is your thing
yeah you have this idea that there's a
war between good and evil and the good
has already been designed
designated the winner that's not true
but your belief in
that it's true until you make it no
i mean you gotta it's motivating both of
us
like i also believe that we're gonna win
because if i don't then i can't get out
of bed and
it's pretty heavy at the moment
you